well a couple days ago it was revealed
that a set of fossils in south korea
were found
and the animal that they're suspecting
the fossil came from is actually a
crocodile like animal
and it shows that it may have been
crocodiles used to walk on two legs
like a velociraptor kind of yeah well
that's terrifying
right that's terrifying imagine if
dinosaurs existed
it can catch you yeah the question is
why after the big meteor hit did
uh animals get less deadly they had a
sea scorpion this giant sea scorpion
yeah that was like six feet tall that is
six feet long that would eat anything
about the megalodon shark was the size
of like the empire state building
not a good time what do you do it wasn't
actually size the empire state building
but it was very big but
that's very big now i wanted to scare
you guys okay and uh
that was the big biggest reference i
could make i like that you said that but
it was very big
how big was the megalodon like like
bigger than a killer whale oh way bigger
one hearing a peep out of a [ __ ]
killer whale
oh the megalodon would it's not hearing
a peep it'll eat a killer whale
that's what i'm saying yeah great whites
when they when they even
hear meters three times longer than the
largest recorded great white
three times three times cheyenne shark
now that's the size of pirate staple
that's cool
yeah that might be 59 feet that's 59
feet
let's just go 60. 60 feet long that'd be
60 feet what's 60 feet long
the empire state building apparently
well how big is that that was a
how big is a killer whale how long is a
killer whale how long
i think that thing is eating a killer
whale oh yeah i'm saying that
but like think about on the hike if it
was like uh be careful there's t-rex in
this area
no one would ever hide well there you go
sir it dwarfs a killer whale it's not
hearing it
for now look male 36 59 feet male is 26
feet oh 59 oh
[ __ ] 60 feet yeah that's right it's
twice
the size of shamu it's not hearing a
peep out of a killer whale like think
about if you're going to hike and when
the
velociraptors have been seen in the area
yeah nobody in the world is going to
hide
they're giant birds that will pick you
up and and
eat you they'll pick you up where their
talons go i'll take them we'd have to
change the way we live if there's
pterodactyls flying over the [ __ ]
planet yeah you'd have to have like a
a hat with a gun turret and a remote
control
i think no one ever leave their house
no i'll tell you what we'd have to do
you'd have to kill all of them
yeah we'd have to kill them yeah you
didn't no ed like if you appear like
well you know we've gotta we gotta
preserve these animals
no you can't they're in the air dude
who's taking kids out of the [ __ ]
well it's a dragon
if you like walking you just yeah it's a
dragon dragon
find out how big a velociraptor was
please it's a dragon
but there was even something bigger than
the t-rex oh yeah
i'm reading these dinosaur books to my
son so my brain's pretty fresh on
dinosaurs yeah they got some serious
[ __ ] velociraptor
63 pounds oh no i'm talking about no no
no no my pterodactyl
find out how much the terror fight the
velociraptor pterodactyl
you could kick it now there you go now
there you go what
oh wait a minute when you spend a 3.5
feet i thought it was way bigger
okay so they're smaller birds okay still
a problem though you know what movies
are full of [ __ ]
i know wait hold on
19.5 feet well the wings man was 20 feet
bottom length of six feet that's a huge
that's big but how tall or how much did
it weigh well it's
underneath if his body is six feet i'm
telling you right now you're dead
it's coming for you wait an eagle kills
things 550 pounds oh you're a dutch
oh you're dead oh dude oh you're [ __ ]
mountain lion with wings oh my god
mountain lions are 150 pounds oh wow sir
that's one 550
that's a mountain gorilla that's a
mountain male 1 yeah you are
sizing that's a male mountain gorilla
with wings that's that's the empire
state building with wings yeah
it stood 18 18 feet tall oh we're all
[ __ ]
oh my god well guess what to kill it
your muscles
we'd walk around with uh ar-15s and just
snipe them out of the [ __ ] sky
yeah you you have to kill them because
they will kill you
there's really nothing we kill these
days unless it eats as soon as it gets
the taste of a human then we kill it but
other than that we really don't
if you had crocodiles that could fly and
run
nile crocodiles they there's no place
for them sir
you couldn't have a nile crocodile in in
the [ __ ]
air pterodactyls you're like oh my god
that's a crocodile tree run
wow things are so much scarier back then
yeah they were you don't think people
would just like collecie it and try to
take that i should train it have a pet
tear down yeah like fly on them
yeah what else dinosaurs are cool
aren't they coming up with the woolly
mammoth though didn't they find like
some preserved meat
they're taking the cells and rebuilding
a woolly mammoth problem
they look like elephants with long hair
like an elephant grew its hair out
they look like grunge elephants yeah on
verge of resurrection they're gonna
bring back their nirvana elephants
can you do one more yeah you don't have
any friends can you do one more
poor little thing poorly i don't even
think of that he seemed to be all by
himself
god look at how big can i go go back you
know how big those tusky tusks are oh my
god
are scientists on the verge of
resurrecting the woolly mammoth
that'd be cool wow did you see that
you see that that's a picture that's
frozen that's a real picture
no tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing